hello everyone and welcome back to the
chest 24 legends of chess tournament uh
it's a game from one of the previous
rounds it's a game from round six but
one that
i didn't have time to show but yeah i
really wanted to show it so
i'm showing it now it's yanny pomeshi
versus vishwanathan anand and
this is game four of the of their match
now the thing is uh nipple won in game
two and he only needs a draw
uh in this uh game to win the match
since game one and game three were a
draw
uh and anand really needs a win to take
this into armageddon so that's uh one of
the reasons why this game is interesting
but not
the only reason uh that's like being an
understatement
so uh without further ado let's check it
out as it is it is quite the game so
here uh nepo opens with e4 we have c5 by
anand you need a win of course you go
for the sicilian
knight of three we have e6 and knight
the c3 now by nipple uh waiting with
the with the the d4 uh we have knight to
c6 and the d
for now postponed by a move we have
captures captures
and now queen to c7 by uh by anand with
a3 so the the time of sicilian is on the
board we have a3 and
now a6 uh we have bishop to e3
and now knight to f6 just continuing
development and now this
is a fairly standard position here you
might see moves like bishop e2
f4 even f3 and such but the move nipple
plays is a new move in the position
so already as of move eight we have a
completely new game queen to f3
it's not a new idea or anything in uh in
a lot of sicilians but for this
particular position it was
it was not played before uh and okay uh
with b5
chances are and apple is castling
queenside so you might as well
uh prepare this b4 push or you want to
get the bishop in you want to get the
rook into the game maybe see it maybe d8
depending on what white plays uh and
here we have
e5 uh sort of offering uh
a pawn here but not really as b5 kind of
made it impossible for the pawn to be
captured because
uh if you capture it with the queen then
just knight captures
and if you recapture the the game's over
you lose the rook here
and if you capture with the knight then
you you've just blundered
the rook here on a8 so the point here is
after e5 anand goes for knight captures
on d4 so
sort of giving up the rook but not
really as from here you have knight to c
to check winning the white rook so it's
not really not really an issue so we
have bishop captures on d4
uh and now bishop to b7 with an attack
on
nepo's queen queen to g3 now making it a
bit difficult for
for anand to develop his dark square
bishop but now
knight the d5 uh ananda
wants to exchange this knight on c3 and
nepo declined we have knights the e4
which is really weird the nipple really
only needs a draw here but he he
continues to complicate matters
so knight's the e4 he offers the dc2
pawn here so
queen captures on c2 and bishop to d3
now
uh asking what do you do with the queen
so here we have queen to
a4 attacking the bishop here and here
nepal goes
b4 and it seems like anand's queen is uh
trapped
not really trapped and nothing is
attacking it but the queen doesn't
really have any squares
okay you could try to bring it back with
b3 but
uh for example if the bishop moves uh
let's say
somehow to c2 the queen would definitely
be trapped
but anand finds the very interesting
bishop captures on b4 now this comes
with
check so you don't have any time to
capture on g7
with a capture sun b4 and the queen
captures on b4 now this also comes with
check uh if the king just moves then the
queen can capture on d4
so nepal blocks it with bishop to c3 but
now we have
knight captures on c3 and this is the
moment uh that nepo takes
the opportunity to play this knight to
d6 check idea
and okay king f8 at least you are now
guarding the the g7 pawn and here nepo
castles and we have this completely
crazy position
uh which is i think is fascinating
because nipple only needs a draw
to win the match so here bishop to c6
anand gets his bishop out of harm's way
and rook 8 to c1 now there could be a
lot of pressure on this knight here
but f5 by anand the f7 pawn could be a
weakness
at some point if the if the queen also
joins the action so you don't want to
uh try something like that uh and also
there might be
some some ideas of maybe sacrificing
with with a delivered check and then
some exposure here
it doesn't work now but it could be uh
sometimes in the future so instead f5
saying that okay if you capture alpha
song
uh it doesn't really work because i'm
just gonna play rook g8 and there's
already a lot of pressure on g2 here
uh so instead we have queen to g5
uh now uh and well just a very very
active square for the queen ideas like a
bishop captures an f5 might be an option
followed by
captures captures and let's say queen f7
uh so here we have queen to d4
a very nice centralizing move by the
queen and now
uh anand is asking nepo what what do you
do here
uh for example if you try if you try
such an idea let's say bishop captures
an f5
then you have the the very unpleasant
knight the e to check uh
and well the queen's gonna capture on e5
next of course you will not capture here
but now the
the rook is also hanging you will
capture on the five uh and so on so
not really not really an idea just yet
so here
uh nepo decides to go for rook to e1
he defends the e5 pawn uh as he really
wants to check matano and here
and he uh gives up the light square
bishop here so anand accepts the
challenge he says okay queen captures on
b3
and now queen to h5 nepo now threatens
checkmate on f7
so anand blocks it with the g6 and now
queen to g5 with the threat of queen f6
checking jade and queen to f7 checkmate
now how do you how do you defend here
with anand it's uh
it's a very interesting position so uh
let's try something different so here
uh feel free to pause the video and try
to defend the disposition with black
while i give you a couple of seconds
what's the best move here for black
so uh for those of you who were able to
do it congratulations on spotting king
the g8
it's important to defend the f7 square
so you really need to bring the rook to
f8 if you try something like knight d5
yes this does defend this
f6 square but rook ed1 attacks the queen
you're gonna capture the knight and
still get this queen to f6 move in
uh or or rather if uh if black captures
the rook if not
uh then uh white just gets out of any
any miss
so after this queen to g5 move on and
played king to g8 now the rook can come
to f8 to defend the f7 square we have
queen the e7
threatening checkmate and rook to f8 now
and now nepo continues the attack knight
the e8 now again
going for this checkmate with queen to
g7 as now the knight also covers that
so rook to f7 attacking and now knight
to f6
check we have king to g7 and now again a
beautiful move by nepal knight the h5
check saying that
okay now if you accept uh the sacrifice
then queen g5
uh check will just ensure me a perpetual
check check check check check and it's a
uh draw by by uh well just by perpetual
checking
uh or rather by a threefold repetition
so here after knight h5 and says okay i
don't mind taking a nice stroll
uh so king the h6 offers a full rook now
and now the game gets really interesting
we have queen captures on f7 by nippo
king captures an h5 uh the king gets
even closer
uh anand really not worried here and
rook to e3 now with ideas of rook h3
check also if the queen moves you're
just going to lose the knight here
so knights the e to check king to f1
and now again not giving nepo a moment
uh to catch his
breath just bishop captures on g2 point
is that you want to get your queen away
from
uh from this rook uh with a temple so
let's say king captures queen d5 check
and next you're gonna capture the rook
as there's no longer
the rook attacking your queen so here
after bishop captures on g2 we have king
to e1
and now comes knight captures on c1 here
anan gives up the queen
as he's already up material so he really
doesn't care knight captures on c1
and okay nepal grabs the queen we have
knight captures here
uh and now this comes with checks so
king to d2
uh and now knight captures an e5 with an
attack on the queen
queen g7 with a double attack here but
it doesn't matter since the knight moves
with tempo so knight f3 check king e3
and now bringing the rook into the game
and here you can see the situation on
the board anand has a rook a bishop and
the knight and
well so many pawns that's like seven
pawns and nip only has a queen
and two pawns so this is completely
winning for black unless
uh nepo will be able to somehow get some
sort of a perpetual or if iron blunder
some sort of a sneaky mate so hero queen
captures an h7 check
king the g5 queen e7 check and now king
the g4
anand goes even further with the king h3
check
uh we have bishop captures an h3 and now
queen here the d6 going for queen to g3
check which would win the
the bishop here however even if this
happens i still don't think it would be
enough for
uh for for nipple to get a draw but uh
you know time is
running low so you never know so rook c3
checked by anand we have king to e2
and now comes uh the the brilliancy of
the game
uh feel free to pause the video and win
this game for anand
it's actually with best defense it's
like a forced mate in 19 moves but
uh you know that's with best defense so
feel free to pause the video and
win the game for anand while i give you
a couple of seconds
so for those of you who were able to do
it congratulations on spotting the
deflecting bishop to f1 and for those of
you who just want to enjoy the show it's
bishop to f1
check point is that if you move the king
the bishop now covers the d3 square so
let's say king to d1 and king to d1 is
actually the the best defense here but
it's only
only imaginary because after this check
you have to give up the queen and now
it's
well a bishop and knight and an army of
pawns against the
the king here so that's not not really
an option so instead after bishop f1
check
nepo captures the bishop but now comes
rook the c1 check
and it was in this position on mu 41 uh
that ianniponishii resigned the game
as there is nothing more to be done here
because if king g2 rook g1 is checkmate
and if you try it the other way uh let's
say you go king to
king to e2 then it's still rookie one
check king to d3 and rook d1 check
winning the queen and again if this
moves then is just a rook
rook knight and an army of pawns against
the lone king uh
and of course there is nothing more to
be done here so after roxy one check
just uh you know resigns from nippo and
anan manages to take this game into
armageddon
uh unfortunately for anand even though
he was able to take it to armageddon and
nepo won the armageddon and
uh won their match however i think this
game was uh
exceptionally interesting because here
uh we're even gonna take a moment here
to award uh
nepo none other than the the most
prestigious
uh well you know what i'm talking about
this is the the first time we're ever
awarding this but
uh nepo we are awarding you with the
barnes head for this relentless attack
in a position where you only needed a
draw you went all out and wanted to
checkmate anand
uh some would some would argue that it
it maybe would deserve more
uh a car schlechta head but i'm gonna go
with the barn's head on this one because
it was
just completely crazy and yeah too bad
for anand
that he didn't get to to win the to win
the armageddon but
uh even uh winning a game like this uh
is definitely deserving of uh
of showing it and i really want to show
it right away but i i didn't manage so
that's why
i'm only showing it now and we have some
time probably before the next round so
if you have some other games we've
missed
and that are really interesting do use
hashtag suggestion as it's
as it says uh below the board so yeah
that's uh the game i do hope you enjoyed
it i would like to thank piotr
uh ishmael rivera orash petrov kimura
and christopher fernandez for your
contribution to my channel thank you a
lot i really appreciate it
as usual you can check to my previous
videos here thank you for watching and i
will see you soon continuing the
coverage of the chess 24 legends of
chess tournament
uh checking up on your wonderful
suggestions and whatever else happens in
the chess world
uh thank you all i will see you soon and
have an excellent rest of your day